للمرة الثانية في عام ونصف، تغير المقاتلات الإسرائيلية على ضواحي دمشق. الهجوم الأخير كان في وضح النهار
الضربة الأولى استهدفت مطار الديماس الذي يتوسط منطقة عسكرية واسعة تتضمن المقار الرئيسة للفرقة الرابعة وتنشر فيها وحداتها المختلفة مشكلَّةً خطوط الدفاع الأولى عن الجهتين الغربية والشرقية للعاصمة
بالإضافة إلى حماية الطريق الحيوي الرابط بين بيروت ودمشق، وفق السفير اللبنانية.
أما الغــارة الثــانية، فقد طالت منطقة محاذية لمطار دمشق الدولي حيث يقع مستودع للصادرات والواردات تخزن فيه الشحنات العسكرية وفق خبراء
الدولة العبرية كعادتها صمتت، إلا أن صحفا إسرائيلية ذكرت أن الغارة استهدفت مخزنا لصواريخ أرض-جو متطورة كانت في طريقها من سوريا إلى حزب الله في لبنان.
صمتُ الحكومة الإسرائيلية تبدد بتصريح وزير الاستخبارات /يوفال شتاين ايتز/، الذي ورغم تحاشيه الحديثَ بشكل مباشر عن الهجوم
أكد تصميمَ إسرائيل على منع نقل أي أسلحة متطورة من سوريا إلى لبنان قائلا إن بلاده تتبع سياسة دفاعية صارمة في هذه المسائل.
دمشق/ وصفت الهجوم بالعمل السافر وطالبت بمعاقبة إسرائيل في مجلس الأمن..الخارجية الروسية أعربت عن قلقها ورفضها القاطع لاستخدام القوة في العلاقات بين الدول
إيران، حليفة الحكومة السورية، اعتبرت أن الغارات الاسرائيلية جرت بالتنسيق مع جماعات معارضة من أجل مساعدتها
بعض المسؤولين في /دمشق/ ربطوا ذلك  بتقرير لمراقبي الأممِ المتحدةِ العاملينَ في الجوْلانِ تحدث عن تعاون متنام بين مجموعات متشددة من المعارضة وإسرائيل خلال السنتين الأخيرتين.
وتعد هذه الغارة الإسرائيلية الخامسةَ من نوعها منذ اندلاع الأزمة السورية عامَ ألفين وأحدَ عشر.
1 ففي الخامس من يناير/ كانون الثاني من العام الماضي هاجمت مقاتلات إسرائيلية منشآت عسكرية في منطقة جمرايا الحدودية مع لبنان
2 وبعدها بأربعة أشهر تعرضت المنطقة نفسها لضربة جوية ثانية قالت إسرائيل إنها طالت شحنة عسكرية نوعية كانت موجهة إلى حزب الله.
3 وفي الخامس من يوليو/ تموز من العام الماضي أغارت مقاتلات إسرائيلية على مواقعَ في اللاذقية أكد مسؤولون أمريكيون لاحقا أنها استهدفت مستودعا لصواريخ /ياخونت/ البحرية.
وفي مارس آذار/ الماضي هاجمت طائرات من سلاح الجو الإسرائيلي مواقعَ للجيش السوري في القنيطرة حيث يقع مقر اللواء تسعون المسؤول عن منطقة التماس بين البلدين.